thank you to better help and Shopify for
sponsoring more on them after the
reaction reject Nation we're going to
watch what I can only imagine to be the
greatest movie ever made The Beekeeper
I'm of course joined by the man I've
been covering all these action movies
with Andrew Gordon Andrew how are you
I'm doing great Greg but I want to know
who's impression is better it's
definitely mine but what's most
important are we watching the theatrical
cut or the air cut we watching whatever
cut regardless it's going to be the
greatest movie ever
made some people say we sound Australian
I don't hear it I think these are the
greatest Impressions you're ever going
to hear of Jason STM on this YouTube
platform anyway guys did you see The
Beekeeper Andre and I've been so excited
to watch this I think we're we're Jazz
we're jacked up all righty Andrew you
ready to do it let's do it leave a like
also be sure to subscribe click that
notification Bell to get notified
whenever we got a reaction up on this
channel thanks to prea for helping us
set it down these highlights also
massive thank you to all who have joined
us at our patreon page becoming super
sexy re IM I kept this up you going to
say how long can you do this I'm
impressed F Tri the Fang Reaction watch
along we syn up with the own copy of
beekeeper John and I also cover several
shows over there exclusively with
highlights and watch alongs included
let's do
it I'm the line
Tamer I hope that's his next movie she
just going to battle every every kind of
animal that exist and I would pay to see
it that should be his his stick it
should be his uh typ casting Bing
kangaroo oh you see the the letters
they're like like Stingers oh that's
neat there's autistic Merit to this it's
very stylized thank you David hair oh my
God there's a whole history to unpack of
beekeepers it's really neat oh I didn't
know Josh erson was in this H forg
thought he
was love this this is going to be like a
secret organization that has spanned
centuries it looks like true historical
Protection
Program Jason STM was a producer on this
I'm the producer I'm the
[Laughter]
producer
ominous it's a good establishing shot to
show it's a shadowy
organization that's a cool mood kind of
reminds me to the town from first bej
juice reference number one those things
scare me to death then killing my
honeybees few days unchecked Wipe Out
the whole Colony what are you going to
do with them well that's between me and
them if you don't mind what does that
mean he's going to torture them they're
putting up with me and all of my bees
this place is crab grass and weeds and
you brought it back to life no one's
ever taken care of me before bees are an
endangered species yeah
unfortunately Mr Clay come back at
supper time let me feed you don't bring
the bees with
you he put like trackers in the
bees or is he just an actual
beekeeper
oh oh my God whoa I've never seen that
done before interesting method damn that
is beautiful did you know Jason Stam uh
studied beekeeping for six months prior
to doing
this I made that [__] up I'm a method
actor no who did that now Jason STM is
going to seek retribution I like how uh
that's all draped in yellow like bee
color United data group good afternoon
this is void how may I help you oh I
hate this guy already oh hello I I just
got a message saying that there's a
problem with my computer why are you
calling the number the message you
received is from our United data group
antivirus software it's part of the
software package that you pre-installed
on your computer oh I'm sorry I'm not a
computer person what did you say the
name of your product is again uh she
seems like such a sweet old lady I know
that's who they Prey Upon the most is
older people there is actually a
software package that you can download
that would allow me to resinall
remotely oh my gosh what a jerk can you
uh can you type this friendly
friend. net spell just how it sounds I'm
there oh this seems like a realistic con
artist prick oh of for sure yeah I
clicked the button so you're about to
see some windows open closed on your
desktop as I reinstall the vir shield
for you wow I hope you clowns are paying
attention you stick to the script you
are not Leo DiCaprio and I choose Rich
every time she has got 10K checking life
insurance annuity Roth IRA teachers
pension and that is so messed up [__]
[__] all right she is a signatory
wow let the scrip mining
begin oh my God that is actually
infuriating just because of I want to
punch through the screen right now can
you log into that account and verify the
transfer please Miss Parker hold
on yes
there's she's so innocent this a
transfer for
$50,000 I made a terrible mistake I was
supposed to credit you $500 but I know I
got a a stuck key here I'm going to lose
my job here
no I could wire the amount back I will
need a different password though one
second now this is the master password
for all her accounts
we get it we zero out everything a yuck
I think I should call the bank please
don't you're probably right but there
goes my job and there goes all your
data oh she a widow yeah and I'm
assuming this is she's going to want to
take her own life after
this
[Music]
hello wow the worst of the worst douche
piece of
crap
uh
oh oh God whoa was not expecting a feel
this much not going to lie Dam this is
real this feels
so which he's going through right now
[__] oh my God these are uncomfortable
Goosebumps I'm getting that is awful a
this poor poor
woman honey looks delicious
though oh I'm so scared she's not going
to be okay smart cuz even if this move
movie gets like cheesy action fun
starting off on a serious note is really
good do you need that opposition good
direction David
a oh man don't you move oh oh [__] drop
the knife she the one from Umbrella
Academy I think she
is now who the why would you suspect
this the one who came in here at calling
her name
Verona ah I'm so sorry well how do you
know
my
yikes though we can clear him me our
best and only per clear him damn lens
flares on the camera this is really
starting a heavy note let's just
completely ignore the big white dude in
her house with a knife get him up
surprisingly effective because the the
communication he had with her was was
limited but you could feel it through
the emotion and the tone I was bringing
her a jar of honey who the are you
Winnie the Pooh the keep
bees how do you know my mother R some
space in the bomb from her have a sign
leas she didn't answer when I knocked I
noted a car in the driveway I had the
smoke alarm and I entered you got a law
enforcement background I told you I'd
take care of bees most badass beekeeper
I am so on boarded from taking out all
those guys guys I was not expecting to
beat this personally
invested you see on the phone all the
fraud alerts and all that [__] there
there you go I'm surprised it still
stayed logged in that long when I
usually get booted out in like 5 10
minutes it's the most unrealistic part
of this movie undoubtedly nothing more
unrealistic is to come his hands test a
negative for gunshot residue but the
prince on the gun were your mothers yep
I wanted to thank you for taking care of
my mom tried to stay in her life as much
as I could obviously I could have done a
better job being old can be a lonely
thing the certain age you used to exist
used to be a part of life or the family
or of the hive I guess you could
say you know I think I know why she
liked you you're just like my brother he
was in marso a marine Raider he was
killed a few years ago kicking doors his
family's experienced a lot of tragedy
she got scammed somebody emptied out all
her accounts she was an educator
director of a charity for kids I got 2
million out of that account know it did
it there's some commentary here I talked
to an agent in our cyber crimes office
this crew's been operating for 2 years
and we don't even have names jeez you
don't need a cyber security team you
need a beekeeper taking from an elderly
person is as bad as stealing from a
child maybe worse why have we been
stealing from children this whole time
Andrew the money's in the elderly yeah
and so help me God I'm going to get
these mother who did
this like how it's like the the yellow
with the Angelic light cuz he is the
Angel savior what are you doing I
thought you retired I did I need a favor
oh he's got a
past a name and address easy this is
exting not easy know even the FBI can't
find these people well we're not the FBI
are we should me the DS and
standby they're routing all over the
world you found them sure but who these
people you want to find out is that this
a good the ramp up this it's actually
more patient than I expected who the
hell you think you're going pal this
United data group this is private
property and you're trespassing I'm
going inside this is a I'm going to burn
it
down you're not going anying where
except write the back the way you came
shut up do you know what they do here
buddy I'm count of three seal from the
elderly one two three there I did it for
you so badass scamming the weakest in
our society stealing everything they
have do you know that's who you work
for yes oh [__] that is what I'm talking
about but it's emotional action protect
the old tell any of the companies in the
building to evacuate now there's going
to be a fire okay
thanks need your attention please repeat
after me I will never steal from the
weak the vulnerable
[Laughter]
again he's here to bring
order
sh repeat after me I will never steal
from the weak and the vulnerable again I
will never
steal here to teach you a lesson kids I
hope anyone who actually does this is
watch watching this movie and thinks
twice about
[Music]
that
wow he's the psycho you're the
cold-hearted sons of [__] what the
you think you're doing I'm a
beekeeper to protect the
hive this is a multi-million dollar
operation [__] okay so you can't come
up here white nighting [__] will you
stomp his ass out
please
yes
yeah
yeah oh my God I love
it yes it's like J Jason Bor me Jackie
Chan damn that was
awesome but you feel really proud of
yourself I've never seen that he slammed
right onto the keyboard that was great I
was not expecting him to get here so
quickly I mean there's a problem you got
to solve it man the next call from your
little fishing scam to this call center
will make a spark across these wires
anything alive in here won't
be I'm liking this more that I already
knew I would like
it yeah from the trailers I was not
expecting to I thought it just G to be a
non action piece I thought it just be
like yeah I just want to watch a goofy
goofy goofy film yeah it it came back
the whole thing yeah and it's it's like
I can barely it's all
tweaked oh those are nice mhm Josh
Hutcherson is playing a douchebag Three
Amigos skateboard it's fake ass hippie
[__] he must be from Southern
California this dude just scolls in see
we're stealing from people and and he
burns the place to the ground four
people didn't get out you're telling me
that this [__] burnt the entire
building down and dropped fouring
[Laughter]
bodies hey I need to talk to you Jeremy
Irons if I had a friend who like had a
call center and someone burned it down
and maybe killed some people you could
get him right get him yeah like
disappear the problem come
on you literally ran the CIA and you're
telling me you can't just find some guy
in Massachusetts listen this sounds like
a job for the police I know this guy's
back right now you're going to log into
our cloud and you're going to look at
anyone connected to the last few deals
you closed what if I find this guy you
get a wrecking crew together and you go
good Fellas on I mean come on you're a
connected guy right you understand I
understood that reference he doesn't
like to get his hands physically dirty
though you good yeah I'm great why I
mean you did lose your mother yesterday
thanks for the reminder remember United
data group you sober enough to drive
where's mine it's an old cup for my car
with instant gas station and hot water e
no are they also like ex lovers I think
that's the application that's clown car
saw everything but no one's talking all
frequent flyers with Burgery fraud and
cyber beeps I want IDs on all of them
you know this is just a tip of like 20
Spears right can I just have this
moment back to business as
usual so in this beekeeper program you
retire and remain a beekeeper what do
the bees actually do okay Widow just has
a daughter in Boston I don't think this
is it
but Matt Pat you are making a terrible
call that's
him oh he knows he
knows what are you guys supposed to do
to him oh no oh my God he knew they'd be
coming yeah ke was talking about him I
guess he's a bee Lover he breaks my [__]
you break his [__] that's why I said oh
no
[Music]
God oh my
goodness what are we in for dark yellow
lighting
now oh you guys just stroll into the
wrong place oh all that honey I feel
like this is going to be fun this going
be a fun gory time let's go hiding [__]
come face
us I bit
now such a
worm it's like
Batman beekeeper
begins do
it oh I mean that is like Batman a
silent takedown I know very
methodical not
even that was
nasty
oh oh
[Music]
boy where are you
here help
me is he going to get the eyeball one
now we we we can talk about this we we
can talk about this this just worked
this out me and you we can f yes
a
why didn't you just listen to him oh my
[Music]
God the action in here is so well
done oh it's fantastic it's really well
done why are people just wiring you
their entire life savings must be your
winning personality they got us a lawyer
so maybe you want to talk to them you
know this is a really nice shirt by the
way did you steal it out of a caset you
dog are you applauding people who sleep
with dogs I'm applauding her line oh I
agree with her oh my bad I misunderstood
oh so you like fires yeah today I do
good cuz uh today's your lucky day cuz
apparently your mother's house is on
fire too and some other
[__] This Woman's dealing with a lot of
what a coldhearted way of delivering
that information United dat grou well
he's handsome you think there's even the
remotest chance that the dude who burned
down United data group is the same guy
we entering the spot from your mother
The Beekeeper said the name of the title
this movie is taking itself just serious
enough you know what I mean yeah to like
it's actually a really fascinating tone
they're writing and it because you you
want the action to feel like th Artic
when it's happening instead of just
hurry up and get to it it's fun who who
the is he tell me who he is right now I
I I I don't
know
beekeeper what's he saying about bees I
don't know he said he was protecting the
hive or something he in the back of the
car there he
is oh he wanted him to make that call I
I got
NF what no is this
man what is he doing is he going to drag
him with the car or you're [__] crazy
man what the [__] bro oh is he going to
drag him uh I feel like it worse than
that man that's pretty bad drag is still
bad oh I think he's going to drive it
off and he's going to go I don't know
let's just find
out yeah cuz isn't the Bridge
open yeah oh
God cool well technically a drag do I
have the pleasure of speaking with yes
you burned up a million dollar call
center now I'm going to burn you down
you haven't told me your name you Mr you
and you bettering remember it
[Music]
you sound young I bet you don't have
estate planning I'm I'm 28 years old why
would I need that I'm about to show
you 80s action dialogue and this is your
data mining consumer service business
right yeah something like that pulling
in 9 million a month one office I've got
like
20 if a beekeeper says you're going to
die you're going to die there's nothing
I can do or or anybody else to stop it
oh cuzz he's a CIA he knows who he is
yeah I could have done anything but I
chose this job as a favor to your mother
I keep danth Enterprises safe is his
stepfather Wallace just tell me what the
this guy is he's probably the last pair
of eyes that you're going to sneer
at that is daunting it's like Jeremy
Irons wants his stepson to die what'd
you get on Clay he's a ghost all I have
is a birth certificate as social never
even had a bank account why does this
guy seem so goddamn apathetic towards
everything Adam clay doesn't exist which
is terrifying to me because he's
probably in a classified program if we
don't get a beekeeper Cinematic Universe
I will Riot wasted opportunity I'll give
you a board seat on the holding company
that's another million a year plus you
promised you'd take care of him you have
my word oh he really loves her my young
friend seems to have caught the unwanted
attentions of of a beekeeper a beekeeper
beekeeper well that's not good
[Music]
dark
yellow yellow is the theme color in this
film he's retired from the program no
longer active well that Chang I like the
reversal on this framing now he's
handheld and she's Center framed in the
camera still the current active
beekeeper lunatic should have been
removed months
ago
almost feels like the Continental little
with like uh with tech
that's upgrade but like lower crate I
hear like fax machines and old monitors
and
stuff got my job
honey
uh-oh get out of
here oh
yes yes you need colorful personality
bag guys let's
go
oh uh what are you going to do
oh you've been a busy bee kill her I'm
assuming you're my
replacement
ouch
God the action so
good
ouch Jesus he really is
Batman oh wow
wow
damn this this turned into a whole kind
of different action
movies
oh
Jesus L her
up
what a burn he still has not fired one
shot in this film really that is
impressive good catch
Andrew okay so he takes the fingers and
I have no idea why did you it's like
dude you're sure no
problem badass work I'm a fan me that
can set the whole G yeah man did he tell
that guy that's civilian to leave to I
hope so he doesn't seem like an evil
human being that's a vehicle registered
to a anet landroid everywhere he goes it
ends up in Flames that's a minigun they
use those on military vehicles do you
know that puppy shoot 6,000 rounds a
minute I do think all this like FBI [__]
could use a lot more personality though
you know it's one part of the
storytelling that I feel like lacks okay
then do you know who Anna at landas is
yes I do I think it's more him even so
who doesn't exist in any commercial or
government database someone who a ghost
like our good friend Adam clay
beekeeping for
beekeepers I think she does a really
good job though yeah I like her she's
really good how are you my friend
good come on leave him alone leave him
alone don't play with those things they
go off oh my god look this is where all
the diversity is and the stuntmen they
got to play key roles for the action now
Simon Says beekeepers have given all
resources empowered to act on their own
judgment for decades they have quietly
worked to keep the hive safe damn I am
the law beekeepers keep working until
they die he's basically one of us he's
not like you got to pull the stinger out
with enough of you then maybe you just
might in fact be able to kill him I like
how they've constructed everything
around being actual
beekeeping oh okay smart I thought
beekeepers weren't supposed to intervene
and why does that beekeeper behave so
sadistically he's getting the location
of every single one he's going to take
them all down we believe that Mr Clay is
connected to a classified program named
beekeeper let's stick to what we know
[__] she totally seems like she knows
this is his next Target nin star United
which appears to be the entity operating
the regional call centers like the one
that Mr Clay burned down why is Adam
Clay on this Rampage tell him avenging
my mother what's your ask my ask a swap
team for starters surveillance support
additional agents analysts that
shouldn't be a problem do she want to
stop him didn't I mean she wants to
uncover the truth yeah she doesn't know
exactly like what any connections are
and stuff Phoenix where we at oh my God
201k
200k I love you how can you live with
yourself doing this crap every Target on
there was an older
person out awful all weapons on Entry We
Ready give me an
o o power down the private security here
under orders of the Governor State
Department certified oh is that one of
the Jeremy iron's Crew He was the main
guy yeah the main guy who spoke up
you're not welcome here get the out all
right boys let's go set up the per
outside it's yellow in the background
closed and locked steel gate want a body
on comms watch delivery dog same deal we
don't see Jason stay them a lot it's
kind of interesting instead of going in
Smoke them out I figured I'd give the
five Fighters a break I put him through
enough already what do you say your mean
was currently I go by Adam clay there
was a back entrance I would have used it
I don't want to injure anyone who's
innocent or not involved he's such a bad
ass somebody detain this
guy
oh nobody he won't kill any of them
wa
damn
oh D he is [__] oh my God why you my
business CU Mr west wild hire me to kick
some beekeeper ass Mr west wild works
for me which means that you work for me
now listen that place is the crown jewel
of my
kingdom they didn't have you so maybe
you just do your job and and don't tell
me how to do mine please copy that set
up a perimeter outside let's go move
letting his ego get the best of him
Greg I love how he lets the buildup it's
just yes yeah we love
you stab him with the
pen oh he just let them clear us so
funny not a good day to dve some people
into this these [__] Not Innocent
for either one of us to close that
distance some of them will get hurt
let's start with this right
here ouch
[Music]
ouch wonder if they're going to go all
film without him shooting a gun so does
Jason S and view these guys as innocent
they seem like they're working for the
wrong people yeah but this would be
self-defense still but he's is very
clear on not hurting on not killing
innocent people yeah but if you work for
the
villains y he doesn't be the best
innocent
okay fire oh good cool
lighting
fire clean sweep you know who you're
working for I business I'm just the guy
they call when there's a
problem you're creating a bigger problem
man and you are a problem God damn right
I'm a
problem
[Music]
oh ouch that would kill a man if not
break every bone in his
face
oh he going to drop the
elevator oh
no
oh oh
[__] please please don't kill me I'm
just the middle manager I never Hur
nobody shut up I'd respect you more if
you look people in their eyes when you
stu
from now you're making a lot of money
here what are you about to
do I know you're the middle man who's
above you they'll kill me what do you
think he's going to do I'll torture you
then kill
you such a cool torture scene
interrogation T it's so simple like the
stapler of a damn make it
stop you can make it
stop dedicated her whole life to helping
people yesterday she shot herself she
took 2 million from a cherry she ran she
was the only person who ever took care
of me it's like losing a mom these
people they're Untouchable no please
please I stop I I will I will let me
sure you better not do some stupid move
I told you they were Untouchable
nobody's un touchable sometimes when the
hive is out of balance you have to
replace the queen I love all
these yeah Clay that man is directly
responsible for your mother's death I
believe you but we have laws for these
things I can't put my personal life in
front of my jaws you have laws for these
things until they fail then you have me
yes the laws are protecting these
things oh no not Mr Personality I have
four kids three boys and a girl
what man does his research okay I guess
he's not bad yeah he would have
uncovered that
yeah
[Music]
colors holy [__] what's his name that's
a son of a important politician oh right
right right maybe now's the time to call
your mother he can't make his move on us
if we're in her proximity can he I still
don't see that stopping him you're
scared and you want to use my mother as
a human shield just call her just call
her come on I'm actually was going to
you know get together with some of my
tech homies and stuff if that's uh
that's cool with you is she podus no way
is
she oh she is oh she is God are you what
a reveal I just figured she was a
Senator or a
I felt like cuz someone mentioned about
meeting with pus or something earlier
and I was like is she pus yeah why not
let clay do his thing your mom is dead
because of these people like Boondock
Saints I haven't seen it put it on the
list
okay we think we have a sense of Mr
Clay's true intentions he seems to be
following the money looks so much slower
on that camera nin star United uses data
mining software to identify these people
and then Target their assets there's
another involved are you going to tell
me the name of this
Company Danforth Enterprises with an
annual revenue of 10 billion dollar
founded and operated by Jessica Danforth
who recently stepped down because she
was sworn in as president of the United
States who else knows this us three
Let's uh keep the circle small that's
dangerous information to
have about the president of the United
States I see his kill count is steadily
rising in a beehive there is something
called a queen Slayer it's a bee that
will rise up and kill the queen if she
produces defective Offspring oh my God
clay believes that Derek Danforth is the
defective offspring of a queen thereby
clay will strike at the heart of the
problem and become a queen Slayer Adam
Clay's next victim is Derek Dan for's
mother oh my God you have a blank check
good luck oh this isn't insane I would
not do that information on a zoom call
or whatever the hell they I would have
th% done that in person go away Federal
Bureau of something or another we're
good all right you'll need to excuse my
partner he's recently concussed hasn't
slept in 2 days we're on the access list
good boss n that's been his personality
the whole movie the whole
movie interesting choice they picked for
that is what it is but the screen time
they give Jason STM just seems so
reserved doesn't it yeah like you can go
like a extended periods without seeing
him mom's detail is not going to like
that well if Mom's detail gets in the
way of what's coming for us they're dead
men and so are we tell them they can
stay in the kitchen damn they call this
a state the beach house wasn't your
super secret CIA data mining software
supposed to I don't know maybe filter
out Unstoppable killing Mach don't you
with me young man peeper yeah you know I
killed one once really yeah only cuz I
was lucky and un
lucky my team will be out shortly if
anyone can knock this guys in the dirt
it's them thought that guy look like
Steven Tyler little tell that guy to
hurry up I want every man on this street
welded shut this is David A's
Twitter the president is the ultimate B
gu oh I miss his I missed the hat out
now he just looks like Jason STM in
every Jason STM movie well at least they
had it as long as we
[Music]
did it's at a Three Amigos
skateboard whoa I'm in there
now
oh I was late to picking up that he was
wearing their outfit although how much
cooler would it have been if he was
wearing what he's been wearing this
whole time and then switching into that
guy's
clothes why does Wallace westw wild look
nervous as a burning cat what have you
done to the man I wouldn't know mother
well he's there to protect you if you'll
let him want to go run the Free World
don't burn it down don't worry The
Beekeeper coming to do that [__]
Love David A's like colorful choice of
villainous personalities he's like super
Larger than Life eccentric random
characters that show
up no oh
okay just coming out and playing tight
the deputy director has flaged his uh
concerns about some uncomfortable things
happening inside the family company
uncomfortable things about the source of
my campaign
funds Mr Danforth are you familiar with
uh United data Group Place stupid I
invested in that how about a Nine Star
unit that's more of like a Consulting
type role this the blockchain issues and
you bye dude this guy's going to get
killed at least we know he's not
rupt he just nods he's
here St Targets in the building East
Wing give me everything you got he's in
the house how did he get by us we're
useless put your hands up now turn the
around is that is that him or no no how
did he plan for
that he's outside Target's
outside love how he's always like 20
steps ahead of everyone well Beast have
an ability to anticipate man on your
knees on your knees place your fingers
behind your
end down what's that in his hand oh the
the detonate the detonators for those
bombs he planted in the cars slide a
hand there St it behind you a [__] whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa I thought you stti
back what are you doing he's not even
armed as long as Des breathing his arms
you're about to see something amazing to
be or not to be he isn't that the bloody
question I think will take to be to
be
yeah
oh shot damn oh my
God I really thought we were going on
film without a gunshot from him oh [__]
H he's
alive oh
it's he lives two weapons three why are
you waiting take it it easy take it
easy
whoa ouch
ouch oh oh excellent this guy's like
freaking 50 something R
Jason you broke the rules you corrupted
an imperfect but functioning system I
was just trying to get you into office
Mom this is a good conversation to have
right now oh blame blame you realize
that you were behind in 15 of 20
counties you needed to win I taught CIA
software to hunt money and and not
terrorists you didn't hear
[Music]
that he has to like pick and choose who
to kill and who not and you got to
elected because of me and you know that
now I know where the money came from and
all the people you hurt somebody in this
family has to have their [__] feet on
the ground to actually get [__] done you
understand
that I like the transitioning Cuts back
and forth between the action and what
are you going to do to fix this calling
the Army tell the truth really that guy
who's coming to kill us that beekeeper
I'm telling him the truth about what you
did Derek then I'm telling the entire
nation and if it costs me everything
well so be it is he going to kill his
mom I think he's going to kill his
mom
oh damn damn great shot nice Shoto cool
I love that POV from below that was
amazing oh great transition cut oh damn
it's easy The Mercenaries are obvious
mercenaries come on
man
oh I felt that might still be alive whoa
we haven't been doing our Jason safe
impression the entire
whoa
oh how is this guy still moving oh wow
bled him
[Applause]
up in
oh
brutal
[Music]
effective sound design
oh oh
god oh I love the brutality of
this oh he got one on
him dude this guy is tough as hell H I
know he's Stu ferocious like
[Music]
[Applause]
force I love how he studied
that
yes oh
[__] oh oh
oh
how much more can you take he's hopping
on one
leg Yeah that's right oh my God this is
severed
arteries that was awesome that was a
great fight yeah that a great fight
knuckle uppercut finish I love it Jason
say this performance there just just the
way like you would like take notes of a
thing it's a cool story to the way the
fight was going you're going to tell
this guy the truth and hope that he he
spares you and kills me instead no d
I'll tell them the truth because it's
the truth oh they've been having the
same dialogue for the last like 10
minutes I'll tell the truth you going to
tell the truth I'll tell the truth
beekeepers live for the good of society
I'm retired it's just personal it's
always been personal go back live a
quiet life I will when this is over
that's all I wanted my neighbor's dead
but do you live in the real world or
just protect it what does it matter to
you how presidents come to be
elected what does matter right wrong
it's not
fashionable it's an interesting climax
with them don't do that so you might
want to step back no I don't want to
sorry I can't do
that truth wait wait wait you put
that oh my God told you he was going to
get
killed drop the weapon drop it wow got
interesting standoff here you decide who
you work for for the law or for justice
job more important than your
mother this Bye
Mom oh full on Cowboy
shot he just straight up revolver
shot let him go and the bee just flew
right by him too it was sick can we
confirm it was a be it sounded like
it your son was just about to kill you
still it's your son I know it's
true H yeah like a western he's amazing
then the sequel shall be fired you let
him
go oh no
uh what is he going to swim back he's
going to swim back he's the
swimmer and there he encounters a
Megalodon yeah
right b no it's
over quick transition we're done I
thought maybe she was going to announce
to the
world uh how she got her Fortune what
happened but I guess we don't even need
that that was that was great thank you
to Shopify for sponsoring which is what
we use for our merch store and is our
gamechanging partner in e-commerce you
don't need to be text have to understand
it allows indiv idual and businesses to
create and manage online stores offering
tools for sales payments marketing and
inventory management it's worth trying
out because of its userfriendly
interface extensive customization
options comprehensive Suite of features
that cater to businesses of all sizes
their checkout system unmatched it's 36%
more effective at converting visitors
into buyers than other platforms and
let's not forget Shopify magic the AI
tool that elevates your business with
minimal effort but seriously reflecting
on our journey using Shopify for www.
reation shop.com it's been
transformative the transition smooth
growth exponential thank you again
reject Nation from simplifying sales to
scaling our offerings Shopify has been a
Cornerstone of our success and Shopify
isn't just for us owers 10% of us
e-commerce backing businesses big and
small and over 175 countries there are
war-winning support always there to
guide you so ready to join the
revolution sign up for Shopify at only a
dollar a month at shopify.com reject all
lcase shopify.com reex start your
Shopify success story now let's grow
together with Shopify team thank you to
better help for sponsoring this video
I've literally just finished a therapy
session and I wanted to shoot this cuz
I'm in this state of knowing why I
Champion mental health support so much
in the past few weeks work's been a
little bit hectic it's led me to miss
some sessions and I really don't like
doing that and sometimes that's when the
weight really starts to pile on a lot of
restless nights a lot of fatigue a lot
of I can't sleep even though I'm so
tired sometimes just a very deep-seated
sense of Gloom meditating and sometimes
journaling are my daily go-tos but
sometimes they just just don't cut it
when I'm trying to pinpoint why I'm down
and really especially after a session
like today therapy just really helps
clear the fog discussing the feelings is
a critical step for me especially as
someone who's diagnosed with ADHD type 2
bipolar and PTSD it's truly a
Cornerstone of my well-being and I'm not
alone in this many of us here at real
rejects are in therapy facing our own
challenges from depression to anxiety or
just needing a non-judgmental space to
voice our thoughts this year I've been
working on most days of the week to keep
my physical health strong and I really
do Champion therapy as a way to
strengthen my mental resilience and for
many better help is integral to that
process There's real value and better
helps accessible and adaptable service
they match you with the licensed
therapist and provide the option to
switch if necessary ensuring the right
fit for your mental health Journey as
this year winds down and we confront
life's complexities do consider better
help as a resource really happy to be
partnered with them this month so you
can go to betterhelp.com rejects for 10%
off your first month again that's bet t
t r h lp.com slre rejects so join us in
moving forward stronger together thank
you again all righty well well thank you
so much to the sponsor of this video
supporting them helps support the
channel so thank you guys very much
thank you Andrew for always wearing an
RR shirt man thank you to all been
buying our real re I wasn't planning
Shing them out but I'm always wearing
them too you're the only other one
you've we them more than consistently
more than John we have so many shirts
and getting one is also a great way to
support the channel really is great
involved ourselves and got two more in
development right now hopefully get a
launch the first one within the next
week or so uh but yeah man listen to us
Apple Spotify we just watched The
Beekeeper Andrew beekeper The Beekeeper
he's pretty quiet in this one we've
watched two movies of Jason sathan where
he was pretty subdued and quiet but
again you just always feel his presence
and you and uh like the way he's emoting
his facial expressions like it it didn't
bother me that he had limited dialogue I
I I didn't care I loved him so much in
this movie but I loved how personal it
was like right away in the first like 10
15 minutes again I I'd only experienced
that one trailer that you showed me
after we watched Wrath of man I was like
this is going to be a schlocky fun
little action film I was not expecting
it to be so
heavy-handed at least in the first 15 20
minutes and like that is a real serious
World thing where you know people uh
especially older people get I mean
obviously everyone deals with fraud and
scam uh you know artists and all that
but it really affects older people my
unfortunately my grandfather God Rest
his soul he dealt with that quite a bit
um and we had to try and tell him many
times like no like you got to stop
falling for this and uh you know that
that's a big audience of who they go
after so uh I like that David a
Incorporated that into the story and
then that was obviously the personal
thing um also too I really loved all the
The Beekeeper stuff that they were uh
you know incorporating with all the uh
the lines in uh crap that I thought they
were very interestingly uh and well
methodically used used you know like
just like the the queen beehive and the
offsp all that stuff it was just so well
utilized um and just like the
organization and the backstory and the
history there was just so many different
interesting layers um but again the the
way everything was balanced out from the
action to the heavy-hearted and then uh
little incorporation of the humor as
well uh I thought very well done um I
think like you uh my only weak point was
some of the the FBI stuff uh especially
more so on that one actor I'm sure he's
a great actor I haven't really seen him
in anything it's just I wasn't
particularly fond of the way the
direction of that character was used um
personally and uh overall though uh this
was such a fun time um and such a
heavy-hearted subject again just with
what happened with the the one the old
nice lady at the beginning you know her
offing herself um and what happened uh
just incorporating real life situations
and then the reveal to that she's the
president I was not expecting that I
just figured just a regular politician
um just some interesting reveals and uh
also the hand toand combat oh my
freaking God I can't even imagine the
level of difficulty that all that
planning took and the way uh you know
that um uh how long it took to film all
of that um and Jason STM he is the
master that was like very impressive to
watch uh I got more to say but what what
did you think Craig uh I thought it was
a really fun movie I thought it was
really fun and in a way that I didn't
anticipate being fun cuz the trailers's
pitched something that was going to that
I thought would just only lean into a
schlock Fest like you said like a cheese
fest of of an
experience and while the cheesiness is
there yeah it it it's it's surprising
like I think in the first 15 20 minutes
it was really smart to lean into it
being serious yeah because if you're
going to go onto this Mission this
Vendetta this Revenge Quest against this
clandestine
organization you need to First ground it
in something that's not just Mission
based you need to ground in something
that is like just Primal which is
Revenge but get you connected to the
characters at hand and you need want to
and the key to any Revenge movie is you
have to want to feel the character's
motivation of getting that Revenge it's
a real I think revenge stories are a
very cathartic uh thing for people to
experience because in real life you know
they say don't get revenge that's bad
most people shouldn't go after getting
revenge don't take the law your own
hands yeah yeah exactly but you know
it's a fantasy a lot of Us wish to live
out and and so movies are supposed to
give us that cathartic experience right
of those feelings that releasee in a way
so I think investing you in that uh was
smart and and I feel like David a is a
political commentary side of you know uh
politics and of course the uh 1% systems
in place corruption well was there it it
was all was a big part of the the World
building to it and there were times
throughout where I felt like maybe it
was taking it I like the first half I
thought was
actually near perfect to me I think the
first half was near perfect in terms of
the the the the tonal balance and then
the last half I thought kind of got a
little too like seriousness where I
thought there was at times I thought the
self-awareness of what they were doing
might have been not as self-aware I will
say you know what I mean like it would
just get like super serious to the point
where cuz this movie has a weird um a
weird approach where you start off with
Jason STM as his beekeeper and while the
movie revolves around him uh in all
fronts all aspects you'll you'll go
these extended periods of time where
you're cutting around to
characters who are mainly just plot
mechanics like you got Jeremy Irons and
Josh Hutcherson interacting you got uh
the the FBI people and it feels like
they lose sight of what should feel more
personal for the FBI uh girl aged uh I
forget I want to get her name cuz I
believe she's the one from Umbrella
Academy yeah I think she is the one from
umbrella I want to get her name um yeah
like because and I felt like there was a
lack of wraparound for her when this
started off as this should also be
something pretty per why does this feel
more personal for Jason St for her it
was her mom who died from this you know
and and the only reason I'm taking that
serious is because the movie started
taking a more serious
approach but now I'm very selective on
using the words but and the words
however because when they say but that
means you are negating everything that
comes before it I'm not negating it's a
bit of a but and a however however being
in conjunction however and but I would
say that what I showed up for
was grandiose what I showed up for was
awesome like the action to me and the
trailers didn't even demonstrate uh what
would make the because to me whenever I
see a Jason stapon trailer the action
looks the exact same like I feel like
it's the same choreographer and the same
fight scenes every time and while he
always does a great job that I look like
the same [__] I've seen in like every
Jason STM movie and then usually when
you check into the film itself you could
see more of the uniqueness and to me me
because this is a hard R like we saw
wrath the man where there's no hand to
hand right it it's it's gun play gun sh
and then here uh it's it's mainly hand
to hand for the guy with this like Jason
Bourne meets Jackie Chan s level of
violence where he use use brutality but
you're using props around you and the
presence of Jason STM of course like
he's he he's that guy who can play
stoicism but ooze Charisma
simultaneously it's a gift it really
he's got that it factor to being a star
and and I think he's excellent here and
the the violence was violent but but
creative yes and packed a punch and and
I really loved uh the and there was
always a bit of a cathartic release and
and I like the sequences too when he's
when he's put in a position like at the
uh at the estate at the very end when he
has to make his way to the president you
know he's got to deal with mercenaries
and SWAT team people and SWAT team you
don't kill mercenaries you can kill and
and so I like how in that action scene
you're like paying attention to if
anything I think this movie really
proved David a is a hell of an action
director because because he has to get
you like follow the action follow follow
this happening uh in a sequence like
that where normally you just only get
you don't kill these guys you only you
can harm them but you don't kill them
and here I like that that was a unique
thing where I feel like that can be
overlooked it's a mix
where he's like okay you don't kill that
guy but you can kill this guy you know
and he has to be like anticipation
anticipatory to that and the final fight
too like he saved a good brutal I
thought like the best fights might have
been behind us early on but he saved
that brutal one-on-one fight for that
very end guy which was amazing that
fight yeah yeah so sometimes I thought
like this movie leaned into it cuz you
know like you got these like wacky
colorful villains uh at times The
Mercenaries or or that other beekeeper
lady at the gas station where that's
where I'm like okay I feel like this
movie is being self there are times like
the the the energy of the movie
would um lose itself lose some of the
the like the The Dread or drama wasn't
strong enough to to Warrant some of
those scenes for me and then the fun
would get a little bit lost when you
would cut to like it was weird because
Jeremy
Irons podus lady and and and and uh Josh
Hutson they really gave like
performances here they did a really good
job and then the one who plays the FBI
agent the FBI agent uh it should be her
right Emy raver lampin lampin okay yeah
and like she did a really good job too
and and I I feel umbrella yeah and I I
do think they uh like lost sight of her
but for terms of like an action movie
where it was fun and I was engaged
throughout and had a little more on its
mind than I was expecting to uh I I
thought it was really good it pretty
much gave me everything that I wanted I
think the first half is stronger but
there are some great stuff in the in the
last half yeah personally yeah yeah know
not excuse me yeah and I I I hear what
you're saying and I totally agree with
you just like on in terms of her
character I get it she's an FBI agent
you got to tiptoe that line on you know
your job and I get it they did come
around to it in the end where you know
she did let him go which I'm glad she
did um but yeah it did feel like it was
more personal to Jason Statham's
character uh which again you know we we
found out like that uh the there was
that line of dialogue that how she was
the only one who was ever like you know
that motherly figure that was kind to
him and understandable but I I really
would have uh you know just if when they
were leaning more on that serious stuff
just would have liked that they were
showing like that she was extremely
conflicted with like trying to you know
do her job or take this more in a more
personal sense cuz I really feel like
that would have been a little more
grounded in the sense of all this but
you know it is what it is um but also
too in in regards to Jason stm's
character on top of the badass that he
was I just loved how you know to your
point as well in terms of like how he
was able to sneak into you know the the
estate and all that he was just so
resourceful and you know that came into
whe whether he was sneaking into places
whether he had the tactical gear ready
to go um with the the suit or to go onto
the beach also too when he uh met the uh
charismatic and uh best character of the
a partner FBI agent uh he's like I have
kids and he's like yeah three boys and a
girl and like he just he did his
research he was extremely uh you know uh
just intelligent he just knew things and
I just I love intelligent smart badass
characters like that and I just was so
appreciative of that yeah I think I
think this was overall like a really
this is a solid action movie to me it's
a solid action movie where um at times I
could like in the last half particular
there were certain scenes where I was
like is this when it was cheesy I felt
like intentionally self-aware yes and
other times I'm like are we not
self-aware anymore and is this supposed
to be like really serious CU at times
you're supposed to be serious so you
know and that's what I mean it's fine
you got to just find a balance though
and I think sometimes that balance comes
a little bit off and uh ese but whenever
Jason STM is there the movie is
incredibly engaging and yeah for sure I
I really thought it it's fine that they
didn't but I truly thought they were
going to go through the entire film
without him using a gun but the in time
that they did go that was incredible I
mean I can't remember the last time I
saw an action hero in it in this type of
film go that long into a film like with
that many action sequences just do hand
toand no guns that was impressive yeah
but I think again that's a testament to
David a as a director uh is because the
buildup to that you know like you were
really noticing sing it too and I was
noticing it so they Reserve when he uses
guns for a moment like they make it a
moment when he first uses that gun and
even the introduction like my favorite
colorful villain play the last guy who
had the the the hallway fight with uh
because even the introduction on that
guy like he's so much larger than life
he's so eccentric and crazy but they set
him up with the with the um pratic leg
prosthetic leg and that tells you right
away like you know this guy can take a
hit so take a lot of hits he could take
a lot of hits put a bullet in his face
leg he's just going to keep coming
didn't care so there there is this force
of nature that just keep I me yeah that
guy had me saying this dude is a badass
too he's crazy yeah yeah uh I wonder if
the there are any fun facts here this is
Jason stm's fifth film in the last year
that's it Adam Clay's birthday oh this
is a fun fact from the FBI file is July
2667 which is Jason stam's actual
birthday you didn't know that was his
birthday oh I I didn't either okay um
this sounds
like when Adam clay EXC himself from the
conversation with agent Parker says I
have to take care of the hive this
sounds like he is taking care of his
bees but instead the first reference to
his former world to protect Society
that's so funny most of this was shot in
England really a lot of this oh F
fascinating I would have thought maybe
they really did shoot in Massachusetts
no explanation of the old Tech
especially the CRT computer monitor seen
film is ever offered that because the
story was originally supposed to be said
in 2003 remember I was saying the
computer I was like this is weird the
computers seem like they're older Tech
yeah uh before the idea was abandoned
however as the art Department had
already started sourcing uh some of the
hardware for budgetary reasons it
decided just to keep in what they had
already purchased oh that's funny I
don't know it kind of like worked for me
kind of like added to the flavor of like
they are so underground you know uh that
was that was that was really interesting
but no this was a fun fun movie Man uh I
I really liked it gave what I wanted
keep scrolling down there's I think
there might be some more really yeah
keep going anything else oh no oh I
thought that okay I thought there was
Nor they get more facts when the movie's
been while long forgot to First St but
yeah no overall good stuff um I hope
this movie is a lesson for the pieces of
shits out there that do these kinds of
things and scam people that if you ever
do something like this an actual
beekeeper will come after you um so
don't even try it um I want to go to an
actual beekeeper and see what's up be
like I know who you really are beekeeper
like um do you want some honey
Craig okay I don't know what you're
trying to say here I hope there are
beekeepers out there who have have a
serious passion for their job who did
not see the trailer for this and saw oh
beekeeper finally a movie that does a
story about beekeepers I can't wait and
then see they watch like this is all my
life like which organization do I need
to join this is a false representation
of me as in my
profession now people who get scammed
are going to call me like this is not
what I do I've been asked to do a lot of
things that are not part of my what my
job entails me to do now all righty guys
well good job David air awesome and
Jason St them what did you think of the
beekeeper leave your thoughts down below
I think they can do a sequel that goes
and wall I would love a sequel I really
would I really love a sequel it's like
it's like an eight out of 10 for me yeah
I would say that too even two if they a
sequel I'd be down for even if they
showed us a prequel just what led him to
getting to where we started the film i'
I'd be down for either or I'm just so
down for this universe The Beekeeper
Universe yeah I'm like 7.5 to 8 out of
10 somewhere there where are you I'd
probably go 7.8 out of 10 okay yeah I'm
like seven point if I'm going to look if
I'm looking for that solid so yeah
7.
797 damn it oh beat me again yeah yeah
anyway what do you guys think leave your
thoughts down below I had a really fun
time and I would absolutely love a
sequel we'll talk with you guys
[Music]
soon